news now live at six live local now one
of the u.s government's premier ufo
investigators has stepped out of the
shadows to openly discuss his work for
the uap task force an organization
created by congress to evaluate
unidentified aerial phenomena now this
investigator is not unknown in fact he's
been hiding in plain sight and he spoke
exclusively about his investigations
with the i-team's george knapp
we set up over close to the doorway
television viewers know astrophysicist
dr travis taylor as an intrepid
investigator of ufos and the paranormal
at skinwalker ranch and on other history
channel programs only a handful of
people in the world knew that taylor was
leading a double life secretly working
as the chief scientist for the
pentagon's uap task force but i would
say
other than the people who already knew
on the task force
you're the first person to figure it out
george as a scientific prodigy taylor
earned advanced degrees at a young age
and has spent his entire adult life
working on classified projects first for
the u.s army then for defense
contractors he wrote a book about how
the u.s government should prepare for
alien contact which caught the attention
of jay stratton a high-ranking
intelligence official who's been
involved with each of the pentagon's
secretive ufo investigations including
awsap based in las vegas atip its
successor and later took charge of a
third effort the uap task force even
before that team was formally created by
congress j stratton the director of the
uap task force asked me if i would be
interested in being the chief scientist
and i was like yeah absolutely of course
i would take off
one of the primary jobs of the task
force was to write a report to congress
summarizing the known evidence about
ufos the team had already created a
classified briefing consisting of the
most intriguing military encounters
starting with the 2004 tic tac incident
the task force whittled down the huge
database into 144 of the very best cases
dr taylor helped write the final report
we picked sources that were we knew had
a chain of custody of the day and out of
those 144
143 of them we still couldn't figure out
what they were where they came from and
what their intent was civilian debunkers
have tried to explain away the tic tac
and gimbal ufos as birds or reflected
light or far-off jet engines as if
military investigators were oblivious to
such possibilities when the uap task
force determined objects to be genuine
unknowns it wasn't merely relying on
video clips for evidence here's the
thing a skeptic and a debunker they take
their results by starting from the
beginning by knowing that the result is
going to be this so they change they
take the analysis to lead them in the
direction to do that and the data that
we had in many cases
there was more of it than what the
general public has what was released
and so when we say that we had a thing
that was from multiple sensors and it
told us multiple things and we also had
eyewitness accounts uh audio information
and so on
taylor and the task force spent three
years analyzing the 144 incidents
including dozens of bizarre objects that
buzzed multiple navy ships in 2019 some
of them were spears that swarmed and
kept pace with the warships others
appeared to be greenish pyramids
task force members were stunned to hear
a navy official tell a congressional
hearing last month that all of these
were quote drones as if the mystery had
been solved someone had to disregard the
work of the task force to make that
claim we had a lot of sensor data on
some of them
that we couldn't determine what they are
i mean
if it's our near peers doing it that's
scary uh but at the same time we also
never found any evidence that it was our
near peers doing it the drone conclusion
was reached after the uap task force was
done and before the new ufo program
aimsog even started so who did it george
knapp 8 news
now dr taylor went into much greater
detail about why the drone scenario just
falls short of explaining the 2019 ufo
encounters and also why so many ufo
videos appear to be fuzzy